[Music]  pundits from both political parties were  extremely critical of debate moderator  Jim Larry's ability or inability to  control the candidates which does take  another look you'd be the judge  and I think that would be a mistake all  right Jim let me just come back on that  and that point which is a small  businesses we're talking about but my  experience that my experience is the  private sector president said that the  government could provide the service at  lower so everybody understands yeah  we're way over the last point I'd make I  had five seconds before you got very app  three minutes left but my experience  that my experience is the private sector  typically is able good ok good so I  commend you for that super Jim thank you  Thank You mr. president  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]